[Music]
good morning
[Applause]
I'm Susan Hockfield the president of MIT
and I am delighted to welcome you to the
MIT Energy Forum and I can't tell you
how pleased I am to see how many of you
there are here this morning as we kick
off our day-long energy forum which is
the culmination of a year's worth by the
energy Research Council this is an
important day for MIT today the energy
Research Council will outline the ways
that MIT can offer leadership in one of
the most urgent challenges of our time
finding clean affordable energy to power
up the developed and the developing
world of course many of mi t--'s faculty
and students are already at work on
energy issues and producing significant
breakthroughs
however these discrete breakthroughs
will have far more impact as parts of a
coherent answer to the energies problems
of the world one where at great science
and engineering are informed by profound
expertise in economics architecture and
urban planning information technology
political science and management that's
why we established the energy Research
Council last year and asked it to design
an initiative to facilitate
collaboration on this crucial issue
across all of the Institute's five
schools I really have to thank very
deeply everyone who contributed to this
effort and in particular professors Bob
Armstrong and Ernie Moniz who served as
co-chairs and also there are 14
colleagues on the council the council
solicited advice and input from the
entire MIT community and from external
stakeholders they listened to
tentatively and their recommendations
reflect deep knowledge and deep vision
now for Fisher Moniz will talk about the
Energy Initiative itself in just a
moment my role this morning is to take a
step back and tell you why I believe
this is a defining moment in the history
of MIT I want to answer the most three
most basic questions about this call to
action why energy why MIT
the short answer to the question why
energy is popular demand early in my
tenure here I asked faculty members and
students to identify mi t--'s
opportunities and responsibilities in
the decades ahead the issue they spoke
about most frequently by a very wide
margin was energy and they spoke about
it passionately and frankly when a
community as brilliant and diverse as
those at MIT converges on one issue it
would be folly not to heed them however
just as significant as the interest in
energy here at MIT is the interest in
the world beyond MIT for the first time
in a generation the public and our
political leaders have both turned their
attention to the subject energy lies at
the heart of the news of the day let me
give you just a few quick examples just
last week President Bush again spoke of
America's addiction to oil and it's
negative implications for our national
security
few of us can read about Brazil's new
energy independence thanks to ethanol
made from sugarcane without a sense of
envy many Americans are shocked by
gasoline at $3 a gallon we marvel at the
success of Toyota and its hybrid cars
and once again we fear for Detroit's
future business leaders and all of us
worry that the energy needs of China's
exploding economy will impinge on our
own prosperity and finally the
consequences of carbon fueled climate
change are of concern not just to MIT
scientists like Kerry Emanuel but also
to the residents who returned to the
Gulf Coast worried about a future of
increasing weather intensity this may be
one of those rare moments when our
society suddenly looks itself in the
mirror
and admits the truth our comfortable
lives are due in large measure to cheap
and abundant fossil fuels yet we know
that we will pay a steep price if our
utilization of those fuels does not
change
as a nation however we've made so little
progress on energy in recent decades
that many Americans are simply
fatalistic about the issue the political
promises made in the wake of the oil
crises of the 70s prompted very little
enduring action as a business energy
tends to be enormous ly capital
intensive which slows the pace of change
to a generational crawl in fact in the
last few decades we've seen more
transformative advances in the way we
consume music than in the way we consume
energy of course energy is not a single
challenge that can be answered with a
piece of technology as clean appealing
and profitable as an iPod it is three
intertwined challenges each vexing and
complex in its own right the first
involves supply and demand in a
business-as-usual future energy use
worldwide
is likely to double by mid-century
driven in part by the enormous appetite
of the developing economies China alone
has been increasing its energy use by
about 10% a year with profound impacts
on energy markets competition for scarce
resources is increasingly global and we
Americans can no longer assume the ready
availability of cheap fossil fuels far
into the future the world as a whole
needs to develop new sources of energy
and to increase dramatically the
efficiency in which they are used this
leads to the second challenge security
obviously we all understand the risks
that accompany too great a dependence on
foreign energy particularly from
politically unstable parts of the world
we also need to secure extended energy
delivery systems which are vulnerable to
disruption whether from sabotage or from
natural disasters we must remember that
major wars have been fought over access
to scarce resources and our dependence
on oil for transport means growing
prospects for conflict over energy
supply and while there is a renewed
interest in nuclear power as an
alternative to carbon-based fuels we
must answer the questions about the
consequent potential for
proliferation of nuclear weapons the
third challenge of course is the
environment how will we meet our
increasing demand for energy without
smothering the earth in greenhouse gases
after all the internal combustion engine
is a brilliant piece of technology until
the price of gasoline Rises so high as
to make alternatives to it economical
it's here to stay we have to look at
improving efficiency in our continuing
use of fossil fuels and possibly
mitigating their impact with large-scale
carbon sequestration at the same time we
clearly have to expand dramatically our
use of technologies that are less carbon
intensive or our carbon free as a
problem energy is Hydra headed
concentrating on one set of fangs while
ignoring the others is hardly a strategy
for self-preservation yet the public
debate on energy has largely focused on
patchwork solutions such as how to lower
the cost of gasoline at the pump in the
short term at MIT starting today we
intend to redirect this debate toward
the entire energy system it's time to
consider measures that will improve the
world's energy infrastructure and energy
mix it's time to support the basic
research that will transform this
infrastructure in the long term and it's
time to make sure that this
infrastructure will suit a rapidly
evolving world so that economic growth
worldwide can help solve our energy
problems rather than exacerbate them
this leads me to my second question why
MIT why are we the right people to lead
this charge obviously no single
institution alone is going to transform
the energy landscape but the unique
character of MIT offers something
important to the equation we believe we
can be a catalyst for a technological
phase shift we have the expertise in
science technology public policy
economics urban design and management to
produce transformational advances we
also have a history of solving problems
across disciplines our forebears whoa
a practical mindset into the fabric of
this institution and engineering
determination to fix it we were
established as a land-grant University
with an active activist mission to
promote the public good we have long
since proven that when we focus on large
issues of great public importance we are
able to get things done the radiation
laboratory here at MIT played a decisive
role in the Allied victory in World War
two
designing over 100 radar systems used in
the war and it established a successful
model for connected science a
collaboration between scientists
industry and the government that
continues today at MIT in the process
the rad lab laid the foundations for
modern electronics this is exactly the
connected model that will help us
address the challenges posed by energy
MIT is also the place where many of the
most important technologists of tomorrow
will be educated by expanding our energy
curriculum we can steer them toward this
challenge clearly given the appetite for
energy in developing economies like
China and India the International nature
of fuel production and estimates that
electricity has yet to reach billions of
people worldwide it is going to take a
global perspective to solve the world's
energy problems this too is an area
where MIT has expertise 10 years ago mit
joined forces with universities in Japan
Sweden and Switzerland to create the
Alliance for global sustainability a
joint research program focused on
environmentally sound development
worldwide and last year MIT partnered
with the Kuwait Foundation for the
Advancement of Sciences to found a new
center to study the environmental
hydrologic and management issues
surrounding the crucial resources of
petroleum and water as a community we
are also in a unique position to push
forward market-based reforms in energy
not just because of our close
collaborations with industry but also
because of our history of innovation and
entrepreneurship a study
Kait ago estimated that if you added up
the earnings of companies started by MIT
graduates and faculty together they
would represent the twenty fourth
largest economy in the world if you
added in the gain from technologies and
innovation simply in whose development
the MIT family played a significant role
it would of course be far larger now
even while we expect to work closely
with industry and government on this
energy initiative let's not forget how
important universities are to progress
of all kinds our diverse talents and our
position outside of political and
commercial constraints means we can try
things and we can say things that the
other big players in this game may not
be able to we very much hope to be
viewed as an honest broker of energy
solutions and so we arrived at my last
question why now I mentioned earlier
that public and political willingness to
address this problem is as high as it
has been in a generation
climbing oil prices as painful as they
may be in the short term are making the
marketplace more receptive to
transformative technologies than it has
ever been in the past the
entrepreneurial and venture capital
engines created to advance the IT and
biotech revolutions are starting to look
seriously at energy however the news
outside of MIT is not the only reason
that the moment is ripe for MIT to lead
an energy charge there is also the
tremendous hope that is being generated
within MIT by our own promising research
for example nanoscience breakthroughs by
MIT scientists may overcome the major
technological impediment to electric
cars the weight cost and weak
performance of today's batteries
advances in photovoltaics being
developed here could make solar power a
more practical option bioenergy
bioengineering research here at MIT may
help us create better biofuels as a
substitute for petroleum and
improvements in the technology of
nuclear power plants could help us
reduce co2 emissions on a large scale
these are but a very few among many
examples of critical breakthroughs on
the horizon at MIT I firmly believe that
university research and teaching can
transform our use of energy just as they
have transformed our use of information
the results will not just be a cleaner
and a safer world but also a more
prosperous world
professor Robert Solow one of mi t--'s
Nobel Prize winners in economics has
estimated that more than half of
America's economic growth over the last
60 years derives directly from
technological innovation too often
energy transformation has been viewed as
carrying a heavy societal cost in fact
it has the potential for great social
and economic gain it's time for the
field of energy to experience a
flowering of creativity that has not
seen in decades there are tremendous
opportunities here for those who take on
the challenges at MIT we intend to
provide the leadership this critical
issue demands thank you all for coming
today
[Applause]
well thank you president Hockfield for
that stirring introduction to this day's
the day's events and I'd like to add I'm
certainly on behalf of the Energy
Research Council and I think many many
more are thanks for the unwavering and
committed support to this initiative
that has come from president Hockfield
and her entire senior leadership team
really this has been the driving element
for our commitment to this to this new
new adventure the as noted almost a year
ago a person Hockfield formed the energy
Research Council that I had the pleasure
to co-chair with Bob Armstrong with 16
faculty from all five schools bringing
all these different perspectives to how
we might formulate recommendations to
the president for how MIT can maximize
its contribution and its impact in this
in this energy energy arena the the
names of the of the faculty are here you
will see several of them later on in our
in our panel discussions today my my
role here will be to provide an overview
of of our recommendations of our report
leaving much of the discussion about the
specific research areas to the three
following panels as was already
mentioned let me reiterate it besides
our thanks to to the president provost
and the deans and others that we also
really want to thank the community
because clearly these 16 people you
could multiply by at least 10 in terms
of those who can provide major and
important input to the to the council
from the faculty multiplied by more than
10 among the student bodies and what I
want to emphasize is that those inputs
in fact were heard and were
part of the of the enterprise we
solicited white papers for suggestions
from groups of faculty as to areas that
they found important that they were
willing to pursue we probably got six or
seven times the number we had expected
well over 30 papers students came
forward the graduate students have been
enormous ly energetic through
particularly through the energy Club
which is now grown to over 300 members
and and have had their sometimes
exhausting
100th event already they provided input
undergraduates particularly through
living group meetings of course with
Chinese food provided substantial input
so it's really been a real community
community effort and as Susan already
said listening on all of our parts was
was key was key to this the next slide
good the in many ways my principal role
here as I said will be to discuss sort
of the framing of the initiative in a
bit more detail than then we've just
heard the the issue of the issues of why
energy and why MIT and why now we'll all
come out here again
but again with with somewhat more of the
of the framing that we used for the
report the certainly energy in the news
today is is instead with a it's very
obvious and be very important but I must
say it is that isn't of course neither
sufficient or necessary for why MIT is
and I think moving forward on this
initiative now because we see these
challenges as certainly having a being
being much more sustained than perhaps
they have been in the past with a crying
need for a new set of technology and
policy tools so here I just note what
you might call the the perfect storm of
energy challenges it drives many of the
considerations of energy these days
three major issues supply and demand
energy and security energy environment
and will come back and say say a bit
more about these but these drivers are
often of course viewed as as in tension
and one of the issues is going to be
defined those technology and policy
pathways that in fact emphasize the
synergies and our ability to address all
of these challenges I will also try to
emphasize why in our view this is the
right time why now is the time for
really a concerted push if we are to
meet the challenges of this next say
half century now it's important to
emphasize as well that while we here and
elsewhere talk about these drivers of
supply of security of environment we
also I think it's very important we
start out with the realization that any
attempt to really project where we will
be several decades down the road is
really fraught with with considerable
danger and occasionally foolishness the
there the the uncertainties are many
types they involve resource availability
the issue of oil availability is always
news but what about land for renewables
for example if one reaches the scale
where renewables can hopefully make a
very very large impact there are issues
of where science and technology will
will go on the one hand technology
breakthroughs on the other hand a better
understanding of climate change impacts
geopolitics obviously plays a large role
in the in the evolution of the energy
infrastructure not only again the
obvious ones about things like the
Middle East questions and oil supply but
also issues like what will be the future
of climate protocol negotiation and
implementation enormous impacts on how
energy technologies will actually be
deployed and secondly the so basically
the message there is of course we really
all of us whether it's government or
here at MIT as we structure our ideas
going forward it's
about options it's about providing a
robust set of tools technologies and
policies to provide the marketplace
with the appropriate opportunities to
respond to these evolving major major
drivers and it's also worth I think at
least we kind of came into this with
sort of a 50 year time scale not
completely arbitrarily as as I will
emphasize because in fact the 50 year
time scale is also part of the next year
imperative in fact it's useful to look
at this historical picture first before
we look forward this is a a plot of the
percentage of different fuels in
contributing in this case to us feel
energy supply the actually in today if
you look at the breakout of the various
fossil fuels the total fossil fuels
nuclear components renewable components
it also isn't very different today at
least throughout throughout the world
but if you look here you see of course
the very important founding of MIT here
at the the transition from the use of
wood non-renewable use of wood I might
say to to coal and then and then oil and
then gas and the first thing to note is
that roughly speaking 50 years is kind
of a characteristic for major changes in
that in that fuel mix this is 150 year
span and we have seen fossil fuels
coming in over this time there's also
one could never could never resist
noting the famous last words of William
Barton Rogers our founder of bituminous
coal and we shall see whether whether we
prove as prescient in talking about
different kinds of evolution of the of
the energy infrastructure over the next
next 50 years but it's also important
- in looking at this - of course
recognize that the order of 85% of our
energy is is fossil fuel today with all
of the implications for that in terms of
security and climate and climate it's
also important to note that we should
not underestimate the challenges for
profound evolution of this energy system
over this next say half century in
response to the security environmental
challenges that I will that I will note
and there are some very good reasons for
that I mean fossil fuels frankly are
very very convenient very energy
intensive relatively cheap lots of good
reasons and also their introduction here
I think it's important for perspective
to realize that as these fossil fuels
came in particularly coal and oil they
really provided dramatically new
capabilities the whole the whole rapid
industrialization many ways driven
driven by call mobility driven by oil
really critical new capabilities for for
society as we go forward and perhaps
discussed for example here we have the
if you like the carbon free wedge of
nuclear and and non-hydro renewables in
going forward it's really a different
set of considerations what you might
call the externalities of security
environment as opposed to the kind of
new functionality so this would be a new
world in both again a technology and a
policy and a policy sense so in
conclusion of this slide I mean or the
last slide really I'll go back to it but
go back to the statement that this all
of this drives us in the in the in the
energy research council but again also
externally to recognize there's no
silver bullet and we really need to put
together kind of a broad initiative
pursuing multiple technology and policy
options where and to repeat what
president Hockfield said what we we
believe we can bring to the table in
particular are elements that we believe
will prove very important the ability to
bring together people from different
different disciplines for
on an important challenge over a certain
kind of time time horizon and the
entrepreneurial spirit that can help
hopefully move us from laboratory to
influencing the marketplace of goods
services and ideas so this kind of again
an emphasis here is on this 50 year 50
year time scale now if we look forward
here is one of many projections this
this is one using an MIT economic model
that looks forward 50 years but the
specifics aren't the issue this is a
so-called business as usual that's the
VA you business as usual meaning no
major policy changes no radically new
technology developments business as
usual going forward the next 50 years
well it's business as usual it has it
takes you from 85% fossil fuel today to
maybe 87% fossil fuel in 2050 but the
whole issue is how is this going to
evolve how do we influence this
evolution that's very clear while not
saying this will not be the the case
going forward it's very clear such an
evolution business as usual will provide
enormous challenges from supply the
climate to other kinds of other kinds of
key issues so what we're about really is
providing the options to have a very
different future as a possibility in
this 50 year time frame but if we want
to influence in 50 years as we've
already seen we better start today
certainly changing directions if we in
fact ought to realize a dramatically
different potential at least for for
evolution this just hard to read it does
doesn't matter this just indicates the
the fact that this is this is energy and
a gross demand GDP per person you see a
rough correlation
and in going up way up here I shall
point out that's that's the United
States this is a cluster of Western
European countries and Japan and of
course most of the world including China
and India are really down here close to
the close to the origin but clearly with
intent of moving up in fact president
Hockfield noted that China alone is
increasing energy by by around ten
percent per year
the only point here is particularly in
the context of efficiency how these
countries evolve for example along just
along these two trajectories would make
an enormous difference in the demand
requirements for enter for for energy so
how technology is deployed in these
developing and emerging economies will
be absolutely critical and another kind
of indicator that I think it's worth
looking at is this is a similar graph
except it's annual per capita
electricity use in kilowatt hours per
person per year again the u.s. is up
here at naturally now it's about 13,000
kilowatt hours per person per year it's
plotted against the Human Development
Index which is a measure of educational
health care and economic attainment in
various countries and of course you can
see the huge disparities by region from
the industrialized countries all being
up here at very high Human Development
Index it's a UN a UN indicator
versus let's say the African countries
in purple all being or almost all being
South Africa the exception almost all
being nestled very close to zero
electricity use indeed even with with
even with a pathway to tripling global
electricity used by mid-century which is
a typical projection the IEA the
International Energy Agency still
projects 1.4 billion people in 2030 with
no electricity and so these are huge
distributional issues that we need to
address it also talks about the scale of
the problem in both the technical and
other
humanitarian senses so that's again a
bit more of the color on the issue of
the demand the demand side and demand
challenges both in megawatts and
megawatts but now let's turn briefly to
energy and security as in fact was noted
there are a variety of energy and
security problems there is the one that
we pay most attention to the
availability of oil in the context of
geopolitical and geological realities
but there are others there's the
vulnerability of extended energy
delivery systems we saw that in Katrina
we see it or we read about it in terms
of terrorism in Middle East for example
there is the issue of nuclear
proliferation facilitated by a potential
worldwide expansion of nuclear power we
see that debate going on also on the
front pages today with regard to Iran
and let's discussed but the distant
location from environmental impacts that
could have significant security
challenges for example in the
dislocation of major populations
especially in those parts of the world
that we just saw the purple dots where
the lack of economic development and
energy availability can seriously
compromise their ability to adapt to
things like like like climate change
nevertheless having having talked about
this broad set of security issues let's
just say a few more words again to bring
out the the issues of with regard to to
fossil fuels this just shows the in
rough terms this is the wrong slide it's
showing the wrong numbers I don't know I
will skip this and just say that I don't
know where that one came from Oh here we
come here we come there we go
very good move them in thank you okay
so there there are the big ones
this shows oil coal oil excuse me oil
gas and coal and the obvious the obvious
thing is what you all know is that
there's an enormous concentration
oil reserves in the Middle East in
particular of gas reserves in the Middle
East and in Russia in particular
although less often emphasized is that
there is also a large concentration of
coal in the United States China India a
few other a few other countries
including including Russia the point
being of course that particularly when
we come to the environmental discussion
we have a very unfortunate correlation
where coal is where the people are and
oil and gas is where the people are not
which of course is underlies much of the
much of the challenge so on this issue
just a reminder because this now helps
starting to shape the technology agenda
in particular technology and policy
agenda in oil we should remember that
what the real issue is in terms of oil
is that our transportation fuels market
is is essentially completely inelastic
therefore we are highly dependent upon
the continuing supply of oil and
preferably at at affordable prices you
can define affordable just want to note
so what are the responses as we now
think about what's the agenda what are
the responses to this kind of a problem
and we can go through this for the other
issues as well but we won't well one
issue is for example addressing sudden
disruptions be they caused by political
move by weather by other other reasons
there are responses like strategic
reserves maintain maintaining well
functioning markets my only point here
is that really we need some new policies
in these areas to shore up our
resilience to substitutes to sudden
disruption then of course there's the
issue of increasing and diversifying
supplies enhance production from
existing fields for example is a major
science and technology challenge all the
way down to unconventional sources we
all hear about the tar sands in Canada
for example indeed there is a lot of oil
but not so nice molecules in various
parts of the world
that would contribute greatly to
diversification weakening the to use the
president's term addiction to oil
efficient vehicles alternative fuels
derived from coal gas biomass new
transportation paradigms be they plug-in
hybrids hydrogen cars these are all ways
of addressing the oil and an energy
security issue they are they all need
really aggressive development of new
technologies that meet a variety of of
market tests however once again we
should not miss the perspective of how
difficult this is a because oil and
petroleum fuels are so convenient but
also because to replace the enormous
amount of energy that we that we use in
oil by other sources be it coal or gas
or biomass or electricity for
electrolysis of water for example but
you understand these are enormous
dislocations of other energy markets or
of land-use issues of electricity
markets and so we really need again a
comprehensive technology and policy
suite of tools if we are in fact to
address these issues in moving to the
third of the major drivers I will just
focus on climate change this cartoon is
just an indicator of carbon in the
atmosphere and the oceans and soils etc
in in billions of tons with a kind of a
cartoon version of of what the carbon
cycle is like we won't go through this
in detail let me make a few statements
however because it's important again for
this time scale issue first of all we
are admitting today roughly 7 Giga tons
7 billion tons Giga tons per year of
carbon in carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere from anthropogenic sources
I'm going to make an assertion
that because of the cumulative nature of
carbon dioxide in particular in the
atmosphere and of course the major
source is combustion of fossil fuels
that we have a emissions budget of
around 700 billion tons before we reach
a doubling of pre-industrial levels now
this target of doubling does not have a
rigorous basis in terms of climate
modification societal cost etc but the
great majority of engaged scientists
would view this as a prudent some would
say too high but a prudent limit and our
current state of knowledge well if we
are emitting 7 Giga tons per year and
our budget is 700 then obviously you
divide that that's a hundred years
however emissions rather emission rates
are increasing we talked earlier about a
possible doubling of fossil energy use
if that would have occur then this
hundred years of course becomes much
closer to a half a century again the
point that this 50-year period is
critical if we are to address these
issues of demand security and
environment and 50 years once again to
repeat the message means starting today
because it takes that long to really
change over substantially a highly
capitalized infrastructure I think I
will I will skip over this just noting
if you can read very quickly this slide
which is of US carbon carbon emissions
tells you fundamentally where the focus
is transportation which means oops there
we go
transportation that's a very big number
that's of course all oil can make the
point transportation is oil and
electricity mainly for serving buildings
is an enormous source and that's mainly
from coal so that that begins to start
to define the kind of space that one
needs to attack with new technology and
and and policy if one wants to address
this climate climate problem so again
this helps shape as I've just said the
the technology and policy pathways
many of these of course an important
point to mention take carbon free power
nuclear power and renewables etc these
are examples again of looking for
synergies because not only do they
address the environmental causes but
they also address security issues for
example and some of the demand demand
constraints so with this framing really
really this kind of set of drivers and
this time scale and these technology
pathways that need to be followed the
council then organized its report this
is the initiative and today's agenda
really along three major themes that we
believe are an architecture that would
be very appropriate for framing are at
least mi t--'s and other research
institutions approach to these
challenges you will hear about each of
these in detail in the following three
panels here I will just summarize
briefly what they are but please of
course come stay for the more in-depth
discussion in each panel the first
category
science technology for a clean energy
future is really about capturing the
idea that there really may be very key
enabling technologies that can be
transformational in this time frame of
50 years examples all of which came in
from faculty groups involve a array of
renewable technologies a critical
enabling technology of storage and
conversion without storage for example
at scale intermittent renewables will
not be practical other kinds of enabling
science technology growing out of
existing capabilities for example
superconducting and cryogenic components
are a major technology focus at the
fusion center providing a platform for
for other work of relevance to energy
nanotechnology or
he mentioned critical for all kinds of
applications in efficiency in storage
etc nuclear fusion I just mentioned
another example of a potential
transformational technology although
with all due respect to my friends some
will argue on the 50 years on that but
we'll we'll come back to that second
general area improving today's energy
systems is the notion which president
Hockfield already mentioned that an
initiative that roughly means roughly
speaking is focused on home runs is not
really answering the question about how
we get from here to there the fact is
today our energy systems are dominated
by fossil fuels
nuclear power is the major is currently
the major carbon free deployed
technology
besides hydro which has its own
challenges and so working with industry
in much more effective use of today's
energy systems of evolution of today's
energy systems of higher efficiency will
be a very very important part of what we
do some here might raise the question
well since these are today's energy
systems industry must be doing all the
work and what can you add well clearly
that is a would be an exaggeration but I
want to emphasize two points there are
key enablers that very much go to basic
science and and really go beyond what
individual firms do such as for example
carbon sequestration which has major
challenges but is really an essential
technology
if for example coal is to be used at
large scale in a greenhouse gas
constrained world we have a strong
program in that there are also areas
where the very nature of a university
having a broad set of disciplines can
come to tools that are typically beyond
the realm of any individual firm even
large ones I'll mention things like some
of the advanced simulation technologies
for example applied across the board in
in energy are very
and finally as several of the of these
white papers emphasize it is absolutely
critical that we address the policy and
societal aspects of the use of these
fuels over these next decades this in
many ways will shape how the system
evolves over these next decades on our
way to an unknown but possibly
dramatically transformed energy
infrastructure in in 50 years and
finally in our third our third major
major theme is one that emphasizes the
global nature of so many of these
challenges and also the distributional
challenges that we alluded to earlier in
that slide about global electricity use
this this includes looking at climate
change itself understanding the science
the policy how they integrate a much
better but things like the critical need
for efficient building technologies
advanced transportation systems
understanding how the demographics of
possible in quotes Giga cities
especially in the developing world may
change our whole ideas about how energy
infrastructure evolved very critical
issues ones that we definitely want to
address and and as I'll come back to
also get get directly engaged in more
than we are today so these are the these
are the three panels that that will come
up I would just emphasize once more that
we believe there is an important
addition ality by bringing together
multiple disciplines that this will make
a huge difference in in many in many of
these areas and to again draw upon our
traditional I think success in being
able to go from the laboratory to the
technology marketplace let me just
conclude with some brief remarks about a
couple of other areas which we are not
focusing on as much today but are very
very critical education obviously first
of all we all understand here how
restriction education are inextricably
linked and for
how it is the students that we produce
who are by far our most important
product if you like the nature of the
energy business that it's not it does
not neatly fit into one department or
one school also means there are
challenges that we need to work on for
interdisciplinary education and we will
do that we make we make recommendations
for a number of approaches in an
undergraduate context for example we
will have two new courses funded by the
d'arbeloff fund going forward the
Gretton graduate courses getting more
coherence to to the program and an
outreach student projects in developing
world countries coupled to research
going on at MIT in the last panel of
today in the question question and
answer panel in addition to president
Hockfield and and Bob Armstrong the the
co-chair we will have Jeff tester who
chaired our education subcommittee Dave
Danielson
president of the energy Club who
particularly weighed in on education on
the panel and also Vladimir Bulova CH
who will who chaired our Subcommittee on
campus energy management which is the
next topic what we somewhat facetiously
call walking the talk the idea being
that clearly with our focus on this
sustainable energy future we can do more
on campus a to reflect that commitment
but be very importantly to use it as
again a laboratory for our students and
our faculty to do research and to and to
learn there are clearly a number of
direct benefits noted in the first the
first bullet lower energy cost energy
use etc but let me focus on first of all
there is an enormous enthusiasm that's
been brought out for working on these
issues on the campus and that enthusiasm
involved faculty our facilities group
our environmental office and a very very
strong student engagement
in fact I'll just advertise some of you
may have seen outside a a solar car
while this is not about a building but
this is about again another group of
incredibly motivated students who are
planning to have a solar car summit here
on campus this summer with teams from I
said yet 28 countries or something
coming together so tremendous amount of
initial initial enthusiasm around or
around these issues so we do recommend a
sustainable campus energy initiative the
next step is a comprehensive assessment
and analysis of various approaches we
would just note that a preliminary
assessment has been encouraging that
using energy conservation for existing
buildings infrastructure renewal maybe
Co generate more cogeneration more green
design of new buildings that we can
actually make a lot of progress in an in
a in a economically wise way which of
course it would be very important also
hopefully as an example and also use all
of those activities as as research
research venues so this will also be I
think a very important activity that
will really bring the whole campus
together as president Hockfield wished
in focusing on on energy so finally and
on this this really is finally that's
our challenge goal launching the
initiative I'll close by saying that
again our core objective is to
supplement ongoing research not to
subsume it of course there's a lots of
activity going on in departments and
laboratories with a portfolio of
multidisciplinary multi faculty multi
year sustained research efforts on a
number of these key energy challenges
the multi-year is important it will it
will it implies commitment on both sides
those who may support the activities and
those here the faculty and others who
must carry out the activities again
mentioned earlier many of these we have
a number of attributes that
we believe will contribute to success in
this interdisciplinarity a tradition has
been has been emphasized technology
innovation I think also it's worth
noting that historically every now and
then there's been kind of a campus-wide
bringing muscle to bear on a complex
societal problem and our response has
been characterized I think by creativity
but also groundedness in in in reality
industrial collaboration international
partnerships convening power for key
conversations as president Hockfield
said frankly will be very explicit we do
very much hope that with this focus with
a strengthening of these cross-campus
initiatives that we will have amplified
the options for the opportunities to be
an honest broker in framing and
analyzing important societal discussions
on energy with their very significant
science and technology components so
realistically we talk about a phased
approach we want to see this build up
over over about five years we will have
to align this of course with with
sources of support we suggest what could
be for example a starting portfolio
around solar power nuclear power
integration of science and policy of
climate change areas where we have very
robust programs today with the
opportunities to expand their their
depth and scope but also very
importantly seeding new projects new
thrusts that will that will follow in as
we build up the the initiative and move
towards things like central research
space for for moving into pilot scale
facilities etc and so we list here again
some of them that span these these three
major areas biofuel storage
simulation subsurface energy and science
where there may be many many synergies
from oil recovery to sequestration
buildings transportation many many
options and these will be realized in
collaboration between our faculty
interests and industry government and
other possible supporters
so finally in conclusion the energy
challenge obviously is formidable
this framing was not intended to
downplay the other challenge because it
is it is enormous as we said earlier MIT
cannot do it all we have no no no no no
pretense about that but we do believe
that with these attributes that have
been discussed we do have a chance to
make a very very significant difference
both in terms of the science technology
and policy options but also in terms of
stimulating a broader a broader
discussion and helping perhaps to
mediate some of those discussions in in
going forward